[Music]
foreign
yeah so
yeah you know what honestly it was like
I don't know if it was my mom getting
cancer I think I did it before that but
like I was just one of those things
where I got to the stage in life where I
had a couple little girls and I'm like
you know
I yeah Tia was telling me he was like
Hey you know you can do these you're at
the age now where it makes sense
see if anything shows up they can detect
like it's it's it's something like
eighty percent of cancers it's stage one
which is amazing yeah and so I was like
okay let's do it so I went and did it
two years ago came back
you know all the standard stuff like oh
we see this here but you know that's
normal like this is a little bit weird
you have an extra vertebrae which I
actually do which is weird
um so a little vestigial tail yeah
exactly a bunch of [ __ ] like that is
so uh I I do that and then I go for year
two I go and get the scan again and they
call me up and they're they're like yeah
it turns out you have a little brain
aneurysm a little a little small brain
aneurysm and I'm like I'm like what the
[ __ ] like this is crazy okay tell me
more and then after the fact like a
month later or not a month later but a
few weeks later my doctor calls them and
says hey what do we see on the first
Scan they found it on the first scan as
well it hadn't changed which is great
yeah and it's super tiny it's the
smallest my doctor said if they hadn't
been using the latest tech they wouldn't
even have detected it at all because it
was so small so it's only one millimeter
and they don't treat them until they get
to seven millimeters yeah so it's like
it's totally fine you want to keep your
blood pressure low and all that but it's
also it's weird because in some sense
like you want to detect those stage one
cancers but there's a lot of false
positives not that this is a false
positive it's something to pay attention
to certainly changing my dietary actions
in terms of keeping sodium low and like
lowering my blood pressure yeah but it's
something you should do which is why
we're having croissants and coffee
exactly well I mean that's
I mean was that I would imagine that to
be terrifying but yeah
it's 45 minutes so it's fast and they
not the procedure the review of the
results yeah I mean you go through it
and I have a couple spots on my brain
and they they told me you're allowed one
per decade and so like you're fine you
have you know two or three or whatever
that's fine I'm like okay that still
doesn't sound good like don't worry it's
like a bruised Apple but that's fine
yeah and then they're like they're like
your lymph nodes this is the first scan
they're like your lymph nodes are really
swollen on the left side I'm like cool
like what does that mean and they're
like did you get your your covid vaccine
on that side I'm like yeah I did they're
like okay that's why and then that would
turn out to be fine and then you know
they found like some other [ __ ] like
there's a little bit of like a a little
a little tail no there's like a little
like like I have this little tiny bulge
in my right nut sack that it's just it's
kind of like the the little stringy
thing that connects to the sack kind of
bulged out a little bit and they're like
that's totally normal it's not cancer
you're fine blah blah so like you know
it's just like
oh my God so
let me just rewind so I make sure no
just make sure I'm hearing you currently
so were you pissed that they did not
have changed yeah that they didn't spot
it first time around I think it was it
was so small that they just they have
different it's not a radiologist whoever
it is that reviews it it's probably
Radiology I think it is
I think the first part was like this is
so insignificant I don't even need to
call it out and the second one called it
out yeah they were just like and then
they compared the notes and it was fine
this is the story I haven't told
a friend of mine
went in had a scan they found a growth
in his brain non-cancerous
a decent size operated removed it he's
fine
but he didn't even know he had it and he
was just going in for for a thing and it
was growing yeah and it saved his life
most likely yeah that's that's wild and
so it's [ __ ] like that and the the
Radiologists want to talk to him he said
the number he goes I don't really drink
he goes but the number of bottles of
wine I get in the mail from people that
are like you say in my life because you
found this at stage one or stage two
I don't know it's just one of those
things where get your Diagnostics folks
and I mean do it more
hesitate to say this but like don't
don't push out the interval if you're
supposed to get something every five
years if anything get it more frequently
don't push it out I had so I have
recently had the opposite experience
with a friend of mine who went in for a
routine exam stage four cancer terminal
holy [ __ ] and I just uh spent several
days with him and
uh not have a cancer not because I don't
want to give specifics just in case
people like triangulate stuff but it's
metastasized and
at this point surgery at least some type
of surgery don't make any sense and man
if you want a proof point for
what someone can do with Decades of
meditation practice
he is
incredibly upbeat he's super happy he is
as productive as he can be he's spending
a lot of time with loved ones of course
but he is
consciously choosing of all the decision
trees
a path of
gratitude and
not naive optimism but optimism in the
sense of looking at everything as
the glass half full and
I was so inspired by this because I'm
going through some hard stuff myself and
to see someone in those circumstances
able to demonstrate that this just blew
my mind yeah and I've spent I know well
enough and we've had enough interactions
I know it is not an act it is not an act
and
I'm really impressed because that's not
automatically the case I mean there are
people including famous famous
meditators who are world famous teachers
who on their Death Beds or in the
process of going through a hospice just
say over and over again to their closest
friends like I don't want to die I don't
want to die I don't want to die and
they're afraid which is understandable I
might be that person I mean certainly I
have no confidence that I would end up
responding the way my friend is
responding but it's been
incredibly inspiring wow yeah and it's
certainly sad in its own way but
a real gift that he's also giving those
around him it's incredible how are you
doing with dealing with all that
uh you mean with with his situation
being a friend is having a friend go
through something like that you know
uh are you gonna see him again do you
think before he passes or is it
something I would like to I would like
to I mean it's I don't know how long the
time Horizon is it's it's uh it may not
be that long
I am
doing well with it
because of how he
is able to
choose to respond to this unfolding
story
of course it sat on a number of levels
right but I mean we're all we all have a
one-way ticket as far as we know yeah
you know my dad before he passed said
there's no lease on life he just like
wanted to remind me of that like yes
like you know it's coming for all of us
yeah yeah absolutely and it's and it's
not something you want to think about
all the time right but
if you think about it none of the time
you also have a problem and this this
has been a very strong reminder for me
it's like yeah
get it together you know like when I had
uh don't dick around too much like have
fun don't take everything seriously but
also
realize that like every moment you have
like this not to get all cheesy but it's
like these are precious
amazing moments yeah everybody's healthy
yeah I think about that with my girls
every day with the kids